Prof: We're very
privileged today and Wednesday
to have my dear and good friend
of thirty-five years standing,
Paulo Zanonni,
who has for quite a long time
been a partner at Goldman Sachs,
and is indeed the second most
senior member of the Goldman
Sachs partnership,
by age.
Today we're going to do a very
informal class with facts on the
slide sheet as background.
We're going to have Paolo talk
about how Goldman actually works
at seeing from the inside,
which will be a rare
opportunity to see the most
remarkable American business
firm from the interior.
It's truly a great opportunity
for all of us.
Then on Wednesday,
Paolo will do a major European
case managed by Goldman Sachs,
and a case which was in
progress when he was here a year
ago,
and it has now come to its
fruition.
The slide set for that is
posted--that will be a little
more formal than today,
but still informal in style.
Please help me welcome Paolo
Zanonni.
Paolo let's talk about you to
begin with.
You are Northern rather than a
Southern Italian?
Paolo Zanonni:
Center-north,
yeah.
Prof: Yes,
and is there any significance
in North/South in Italy?
Paolo Zanonni:
Yes, I think there's
significance.
Prof: Are there--how
many people of Southern Italian
descent in the room?
Sort of?
Student:  Sicily.
Prof: Okay.
How do most Northern Italians
look on that distinction?
Paolo Zanonni:
They look at that
distinction like the South was
almost a colony,
occupied or conquered in 1861,
and never really--
sort of conquered but that
never really assimilated.
Prof: Assimilated;
the North is the industrial and
business part of Italy,
is that a fair statement?
Paolo Zanonni:
The North is the most
industrialized part,
yes, but in the South you
have--I don't think you want to
go into the Italian political
economic system,
but in the South you have
certain areas that have a
reasonably high level of
industrialization.
Prof: Paolo you came
from--you first arrived in the
states in what year?
Paolo Zanonni:  1973.
Prof: 1973 and you came
as a graduate student in the
Yale Political Science
Department.
I remember it well.
Paolo Zanonni:  Yeah.
Prof: Paolo became an
outstanding touch football
player.
Paolo Zanonni:
Too small for that.
Prof: No,
no you were really good at it.
You even picked up the brawl
language of the game.
Paolo Zanonni:
That's--size there is
different.
Prof: The--and you left
Yale?
Paolo Zanonni:  In 1978.
Prof: In 1978 to go to
work for Johnny at Fiat?
Paolo Zanonni:  Yep.
Prof: Tell us a little
about that stint.
Paolo Zanonni:
That's the--
I worked for the Chairman of
the Board and also the owner of
the controlling stake at Fiat
for about five or six years--
Prof: Right.
Paolo Zanonni:
--and after,
I became--I wanted to do some
more operational experience and
so I went to manage the
international business
development department at Fiat.
In that capacity I spent about
five years in Washington,
here, because we had asked
Chairman of Fiat U.S.A.,
because we had some issues with
the then U.S.
Government, and after,
I spent two years in Moscow in
1990 and 1991.
Prof: What were you
looking at in Moscow?
Paolo Zanonni:
In Moscow I was looking to
acquire the largest Russian
manufacturer of automobiles that
the government--
first the government of the
Soviet Union,
and second the government of
the Russia Republic,
when the Soviet Union was
dismembered,
or disappeared,
I decided to buy
>
That company has been
established by Fiat as a wholly
owned company from--
wholly owned by the Soviet
state about fifteen years
earlier,
and so it was based on Fiat
technology and both Gorbachev
first and Yeltsin afterward
wanted to privatize,
and I was sent there to try to
buy it,
unsuccessfully.
Prof: Ultimately--you
ultimately walked away from the
deal as I understand it?
Paolo Zanonni:  Yeah.
We walked away because there
was no deal for the simple
reason that the management and
the region,
some area region wanted to
become owners of the factory and
have ownership of the asset and
100% control on the profits,
and on the cash flow,
and so they were definitely--
they were not willing to sell
it to a foreigner.
Prof: So that's a
non-starter.
Then after the stint in Russia?
Paolo Zanonni:
I did a couple years more
at Fiat, and after,
I decided to join Goldman.
Prof: Then you joined
Goldman?
Paolo Zanonni:  Yeah.
Prof: And you joined
them as--what was your title at
that time?
Paolo Zanonni:
At that time,
Goldman did not have managing
directors,
as opposed to--so it only had
vice president--
sorry it had
associate--analyst,
associate,
and vice president of various
degrees of seniority and I
joined them as a--
the last degree of vice
president, and after,
I became managing director in
1997 and a partner in 2000.
Prof: Let's now turn to
Goldman.
I'm talking to these people now
for a second.
You'll remember the stark
contrast we've drawn between the
ownership for--
of joint stock corporations,
publicly traded joint stock
corporation on the one hand,
and a partnership on the other.
Can somebody help us out by
naming the two or three
variables on which those two are
most importantly different?
Okay I'll settle for one
variable.
Student:  Liability.
Prof: Okay limited
liability in the case of the
joint stock corporation;
good.
Another?
Student:  Liquidity.
Prof: Liquidity;
huge difference.
You can't sell your partnership
in Goldman.
Another?
Student:  Partnership
income is not taxed separate
from the
>
Prof: The partnership is
invisible in the tax codes so
that the proceeds--
Paolo Zanonni:
The individuals get taxed,
the individual partners get
taxed.
Prof: The individuals
get taxed, okay but it in effect
saves one layer of taxation.
Yes.
Student:  The right or
ability to make management
decisions.
Prof: Okay so that in
the case of a partnership
everyone has a management job,
all the partners have
management jobs.
Whereas, with a corporation you
have centralized management
where the board appoints a chief
executive and a chief executive,
at least in theory,
is responsible for appointing
everyone else,
and finally,
how did the two do as media for
raising capital?
The mechanism for raising
capital;
back to Paolo.
Student:  A joint stock
corporation is much more
scalable.
It's got greater scalability;
you can raise a lot more
capital than a partnership.
Prof: Okay.
The joint stock corporation was
created as a mechanism for
gathering up capital in very
large quantities and it's good
at it.
Now back to Paolo.
Historically,
Goldman was straight-forwardly
a partnership?
Paolo Zanonni:
It was a partnership up to
1999, but you have read the case
study with the IPO of Goldman
Sachs.
Prof: And it was an
extraordinary partnership with
an extraordinary record of
success in nearly all of its
history.
Is that a fair statement?
Paolo Zanonni:
In 1999 with--it's a fair
statement.
There are a couple of
exceptions--1929.
Prof: Tough on a lot of
people.
Paolo Zanonni:
Yes, tough on a lot of
people.
Especially tough--almost killed
the partnership.
There is another exception
which is interesting for your
class because usually investment
bank and securities firms tend
to do badly,
tend to be very cyclical,
and to do badly on the downturn
and well on the upturn.
There was one exception,
one exception,
at least as far as Goldman is
concerned,
which is very interesting,
everybody else was doing very
well in 1994 but Goldman was
doing very badly and it almost
killed the partnership.
As badly as--almost as badly in
1928, and as badly as the crisis
or >
and the reason for that,
and that again,
mixed blessings,
one of the facts of life.
The reason why Goldman was
doing very badly was because
Goldman has tried very
aggressively to do proprietary
trading,
especially in fixed income,
and that was not really part of
the Goldman culture.
The risk management and the
trading organization of Goldman
was very bad,
and in 19--toward the end of
1994, second half of 1994,
Goldman started having losses
at that time that were
staggered,
especially for a partnership.
Almost the--the capital of the
partnership was almost wiped
out,
and actually that's where the
firm had the remarkable ability
of select--
a group of leaders that
knew--that came from trading,
knew proprietary trading very
well,
even if some of them were not
born in the same--
in that same organization,
and were able to restructure
the trading philosophy and
especially the risk management
function of Goldman and probably
one of the reasons why Goldman
has done not so badly when the
credit crunched,
is because of that overhaul of
the risk management and of the
trading format style,
and control of the autonomy of
the traders.
Actually the two people that
did it,
one was Corzine who was a
managing partner when the firm
went public,
and the other was Lloyd
Blankfein who is CEO today.
Prof: Corazine may be
available for--
Paolo Zanonni:
If he could come back to
Goldman.
Prof: Kidding.
Paolo Zanonni:
I think it he wants too.
Prof: The mood--just
notice the style of which Paolo
just said something.
He said Goldman has done fairly
well in the current crisis.
Now that's a huge
understatement;
Goldman has blown the doors off
the current crisis.
Paolo Zanonni:
End of 2008 wasn't a nice
period.
Prof: It was an ugly
period, but compared with all
its competitors,
in this and in many other
matters, Goldman has been
absolutely tops,
and part of the culture is not
to--chest thumping is not the
Goldman style.
There's a very understated
style that emerges,
and which Paolo,
I think, embodies.
Now the move to a
corporation--corporate ownership
form has an obvious upside in
raising capital,
but an apparent downside in
changing the incentives for top
management in a way that might,
at first blush,
seem likely to undermine the
cultural strengths of the
historical partnership.
Paolo Zanonni:  Yeah.
Prof: Why don't I shut
up for quite a while now and
let's get you talking about how
that has been accomplished and
how it works,
and somewhere or another we
ought to talk about how people
are recruited to the partnership
and to leadership roles in the
firm,
and how that might relate to
the style of management that you
get with Goldman.
Paolo Zanonni:
I'm sure that you are--I'm
sure that in Doug's course you
have gone through it and parties
in the case that I have read.
The two advantages of a
partnership,
especially in the investment
banking world,
and a securities firm how it
might be is one that as opposed
to the joint stock corporation
in which Doug--
that Doug discussed with you,
in a partnership there is no
split between management and
ownership.
The owners of the capital of
the firm are also the managers
of the company,
and so that's a--creates a set
of incentives but by not
distinguishing between provider
of capital and the people that
have the control of the
operation of the firm.
In Goldman, every generation of
partners and leaders have always
been convinced that this was a
great advantage.
The other advantage that you
have is that--
and this is an advantage
especially in investment banking
and securities firm,
which are people business,
they have no--
if you look at these companies
they are remarkable in the
amount of sales of revenues that
they have,
they have no fixed capital.
They have no buildings,
most of the buildings are
leased,
they have no plant and
equipment, they have no patents,
it's just a people's business
and so when you are running a
people's business one of your
core competencies has got to be
the ability of coordinating the
behavior to those people
3,000/4,000/20,000 and Goldman
has only been convinced that the
partnership structure,
it's ideal to coordinate the
behavior of the top echelon of
the firm.
So the real challenge that
Goldman was facing when Goldman
decided to go public was to try
to combine the advantages of the
joint stock corporation,
especially in raising permanent
capital,
because the partnership capital
is not permanent.
It's limited,
but if you are very successful,
the limitations are not so much
on the size as they are on the
availability on the capital for
a long period of time,
because of course you can put
restrictions on the partners on
taking away the capital when
they become limited,
but those restrictions will
just prolong their ability to
take capital out.
If not, nobody would like to be
a partner, if the capital cannot
be taken out.
Goldman tried to--the then
leadership of Goldman tried to
combine the advantages of the
partnership as far as having the
owner management--
to get the owners managers to
manage the company and the
ability to coordinate behavior.
What Goldman tried to do and is
a unique form of corporate
governance, is the partnership
that is also a joint stock
company.
For instance,
a title of partner was not
eliminated,
and Goldman built a structure
in which partners are rewarded
and incentivized in a different
way than the other stockholders.
The other thing that Goldman
decided to do was,
which is unusual in a joint
stock company,
and you won't find it in any
other partnership that has
become a joint stock company,
was to maintain the structure
of the selection of leadership;
i.e., the selection of the
partners almost as it was before
it became a joint stock company.
Prof: Maybe too--
Paolo Zanonni:
So what you have--
let me try to--what you have is
that you have the legal form of
a joint stock liability company
imposed into an organization
that,
as organizational structure,
and institutional government,
except at the top,
has maintained the same
institution and the same type of
leadership selection that you
had in the partnership--
let's say partnership pre-IPO.
Prof: Okay,
so let's talk about this
leadership selection process
beginning with the entering
classes of employees.
Paolo Zanonni:
Usually when you enter
Goldman you are given a class,
like you are given a class when
you went to Yale,
you are the class of 2007/2008.
Prof: We designate them
by the year.
Paolo Zanonni:
At the end that's correct.
We designate it by the year in
which they start.
There is some sort of courses
in which you are generally
considered for partnership once
you have spent a fair amount of
time in the firm,
and once you have been--you
have done a stint as a managing
director.
When your class is up for
partnership there--
Prof: How big are these
classes, more or less?
Paolo Zanonni:
It depends,
but let's say that they are a
few hundred people.
Prof: 500 maybe?
Paolo Zanonni:
No, a little less
because--
Prof: 400?
Paolo Zanonni:
Between 400 and 200--it
also depends because,
you know, the partnership has
been--it's not--there is no
erasure.
When we went public the
partnership--the partners were
about 200 ten years ago.
There were still less than 300
three years ago,
or four years ago,
now there are more than 400.
There will be a lot less in
2010.
Prof: Okay,
so you've got these groups of a
few hundred and at a certain
point it comes time--
Paolo Zanonni:
It comes time to be
considered.
For someone that has done--that
they have had normal career,
it comes time to be considered.
The way the selection works is
the partners of each division
make two or three lists of all
the candidates of their own
division,
an A list, a B list,
and a C list.
The A list is the best
candidate, the B list is the
candidate that are somewhere in
between,
and the C list is the
candidates that are not--
that do not have a lot of
chances in that particular year.
The partnership selection gets
done every two years,
even years,
2000/2002/2004/2006/2008/2010.
Once these selections--when the
first selection has been done,
what the firm does is takes a
group of people and charge them
with the task of asking the
community of mostly of the
professionals about the
candidates,
and so there are a group of
people that conduct rigorous--
reasonably rigorous interviews
among everyone that has worked
with everyone.
A large number of the
people--of the professionals
that have worked with the
partner's candidate,
be they more senior peers,
or more junior,
to try to gauge the quality of
that individual,
and even more,
the quality of that individual
vis-a-vis,
the group that is being
considered as partner.
This is a process that sounds
easy, but it's a process that
takes about two months.
Prof: If I remember our
conversation correctly,
the firm insists on people
making pair wise comparisons?
Paolo Zanonni:
The first insists on
people make--
doing a qualitative analysis,
and after making--
make a ranking of everybody
they know,
first, second,
third, fourth,
and fifth;
and in certain cases making
pair wise.
When there are two candidates
that are in a similar position,
making pair wise comparison,
which is a nice--
which is an old way to do
leadership selection.
Because my understanding--but
it my--
it's an understanding is that
it was reasonably well used in
the Catholic Church orders on
the twelfth--
eleventh centuries.
Actually there is someone that
proposed that in electing the
Pope, the Pope had to be elected
doing pair wise comparison of
the candidates.
Prof: Well did the Roman
Catholic Church is one of the
few organizations with more
distinguished administrative
history than Goldman Sachs.
Paolo Zanonni:
I don't know one of the
few, but definitely.
I think that Goldman
consciously or unconsciously
copied some of the--at least
some of the criteria used by the
Catholic Church.
Prof: As you listen to
this, think about what this
process would do to your
thinking if you were a junior
person at Goldman Sachs.
This is all designed to shape
and mold a certain kind of
person--of persona and
management style.
Paolo Zanonni:
And behavior--
Professor Douglas W.
Paolo Zanonni:
And behavior in your daily
business.
Prof: So--and you
mentioned in our conversation
this morning an element of the
process called cross roughing.
Paolo Zanonni:
The cross roughing is the
one you just mentioned.
Prof: Is there a bridge
player in the room?
Cross roughing is a bridge term?
Paolo Zanonni:
I'll try to find out what
it means exactly.
I have no idea.
Prof: Is there not one
bridge player in this room?
That's an interesting fact.
I think it--
Paolo Zanonni:
Lots of poker players but
very few bridge players.
Prof: What's cross
roughing in this process?
Paolo Zanonni:
It is a process of a group
of people selected to search
about the--it's the one that
I've just described.
That search about the qualities
of the various candidates.
Prof: But it's
from--they're not in the same--
Paolo Zanonni:
They're not in the same
division.
Professor Douglas W.
Rae:  --their division.
Paolo Zanonni:
They are not in the same
division.
They belong to another division.
Of course when you look at an
organization you have to think
about the organization.
I'm getting to theoretical,
sorry too abstract,
you have to think about the
organization in two dimensions,
vertical and horizontal.
If you take the divisions they
are like the business in your
normal industrial organization
and they cut vertically.
If you take the partnership it
cuts the organization
horizontal.
If you want to have a very
effective organization you
should have a good blend and a
two mix of horizontal cleavages
let's say and vertical ones,
so the way the selection to the
partnership is done,
because of course you cannot
have a group of people that look
at 500 candidates,
or 200 candidates,
you do it by division.
The first selection is done by
division.
When you do the least,
the least are done by the
division,
but afterward since you--since
the people that will do the
selection are the gatekeeper to
a horizontal cleavage in a
horizontal organization,
they are not--that gate are not
kept by people from the same
division,
but they are kept by people
from another division because
you are moved to a horizontal
organization that should
coordinate the top of the
various vertical divisions.
Prof: So this is a
way--in part of checking the
tendency of divisions of the--
Paolo Zanonni:  Silos
Prof:
>
Paolo Zanonni:
Becoming silosis.
Prof: Silos--I heard
last week a great expression to
this,
for a frog at the bottom of the
well,
the sky is very small,
and that's certainly true in
many organizations right,
where people get into their
little parts and they're not
seeing what other people are
seeing across the other
divisions.
Paolo Zanonni:
Not only,
and having gone through a fair
amount of restructuring in my
professional life,
both in an industrial
organization--
in a partnership and in an
investment bank that was a
limited liability company,
when you get to restructuring
it is very difficult to make a
rational decision if the
organization is mostly based on
vertical division,
because the vertical logic
limits to some extent--
not to some extent,
limits to a major extent,
the horizontal movement of
individuals.
So you tend to consider them
only on a vertical scale,
and when on the contrary,
you are trying to restructure
the organization or change the
organization,
or reduce the number or develop
new business units,
you have to be able to cut
across a vertical division,
because if not,
you utilize your manpower
badly,
and you give your people a
limited set of choice.
They can only move either up or
down,
but not sideways,
or the move sideways becomes
difficult,
and if the move sideways
becomes very difficult,
it becomes very difficult for
the organization to follow new
business opportunities because
those tend to be lateral.
Its increase in scope,
not the increase in depth.
Sorry we tend to become too
abstract, sorry.
I'm sorry.
Prof: What are the
qualities that are most
important to cultivate?
Students, you've seen the
fourteen commandments in the
case?
Paolo Zanonni:
Fourteen business
principles.
Prof: Business
principles, seen from inside,
commandments seen from
outside--what are we trying to
achieve here,
the behavior of the partnership
and those who aspire to be in
the partnership?
What would be the top two or
three qualities?
Paolo Zanonni:
A reasonable degree of
autonomy and independence,
but without getting too
independent--
without pushing the independent
to some extreme that it gets
disruptive for the organization,
so if you want you try to
strike a balance between
independence,
creativity, and conformity,
and historically I think
Goldman has a premium to some
extent on conformity versus
creativity.
I think that there are a fair
amount of innovations in which
Goldman has come second or third
and other firms have had--
have been a lot more creative,
or somewhat more creative,
so you try to strike that
balance and of course one of the
characteristic of that balance
is the adherence to a very
reasonably straight belief
system,
or corporate culture.
Prof: How about chest
thumping and conspicuous display
of wealth?
Paolo Zanonni:
Chest thumping definitely
is out.
A conspicuous display of wealth
I would say, consider the
standard of the industry is not
too bad, but consider the
standard of the industry.
If you look at it from the
outside the industry,
it's hard to judge,
but it seeing it from the
inside,
at least its frowned upon,
it's not considered--
actually it's sanctioned to
some extent.
Prof: Well, and--
Paolo Zanonni:
Precisely.
Prof: --and it can
actually, if I'm not mistaken,
damage a Goldman career if you
are sort of wildly ostentatious
and pick up $10,000 restaurant
tabs and that sort of thing.
Paolo Zanonni:
Yeah, it usually--you
usually don't do it twice.
Prof: So Goldman--
Paolo Zanonni:
What is the--let me think
about, for a moment,
about another characteristic.
Within the limits of the
adherence to a straight belief
system,
and I know the two things seem
contradictory,
it also pushes you to be an
entrepreneurial because de
facto partners run their own
business unit.
The levels of hierarchy are
very, very, very short.
The organization is very flat,
and one of the reasons why it's
flat is it's trying to foster
entrepreneurship,
especially in the partners,
because,
see, the business in which
Goldman operates,
the industry in which Goldman
operates,
and you will see it,
I'll to give some examples in
the printout that you have,
changes very, very quickly.
For instance if you take a
picture--we don't give those
details for many,
many reasons,
one of which is they change too
often.
If you take the
thirty-six--let's say thirty
major business lines of Goldman
five years ago,
they are not the same as what
they are today,
so--because the environment
changes so fast that if you
are--
if you still try to operate and
maximize,
or be efficient in the business
of yesterday,
or of this morning,
mostly you are--
so if you are a good manager
maybe you are a bad interpreter
and you are missing new
opportunities of the changes and
the changes the environment
creates.
What the firm is trying to do
is to have global leaders that
more or less think along similar
lines,
but that are able to capture
new opportunities and new
business line.
Let's take--let's for
instance--I'll start to make
some examples;
we run the risk of being too
abstract.
Let's take, for instance,
I'm sure that some of you,
most of you,
are familiar with the crisis of
the savings and loan association
of the U.S.
at the end of the 1980s.
Before that crisis Goldman
Sachs had never done a real
estate principal investment,
never.
Didn't even own the building
where they were because they
thought that there were no
capabilities inside the firm for
making investments.
Actually when they--what was it
National Trust,
or whatever,
what was the trust that the
federal government--
Prof: RTC.
Paolo Zanonni:  Yeah.
When they started--when the
RTC, or at least the national
struggle,
the federal owner of all the
real estate property,
if you remember,
most of the crisis originated
from the loans that the savings
and loan association had done,
especially for real estate
developers,
so of course the federal
authority that ran--
the bureaucrats,
in good sense,
that ran that authority started
selling a lot of real estate
cheap all over the United
States.
It was obvious that there was a
business opportunity there,
but it was also obvious that
Goldman didn't know about how to
do it,
because I mean IPOs,
rate defense,
trading of stock--
of loans, yes,
but never real estate.
An exceedingly smart person,
who by the way happens to be a
Yale graduate,
saw the opportunity,
saw the lack of capability,
and decided to form a
partnership with someone that
knew a lot about real estate all
over the United States and
didn't have any capital.
Goldman started buying real
estate,
and real estate loans,
for themselves--
or for ourselves and for
investors,
and they--the massive
investment history of Goldman in
real estate,
both real estate asset and real
estate loans,
started then just because of
the opportunity--
because of the opportunity
offered by this trust
corporation that was selling a
large amount of real estate,
obviously very cheap and the
ability of one of the partners
to see that there was an
opportunity,
but that inside the firm there
was no capability and
understanding which one was
cheap and which one was not
cheap.
It seemed cheap but maybe it's
too expensive,
but it would have been a bad
investment anyway.
And at the end,
the partner that we had got
tired,
he made too much money and--but
he had transferred enough
knowledge to the partners and we
bought it out and made
>
The same is true with our huge
private equity.
We--when I joined the firm we
didn't do much private equity.
We did it on behalf of clients,
we advised them when they are
buying or selling companies,
but we didn't do it on our own.
On the contrary,
immediately after the crisis of
2000,
the dot com crisis,
we started seeing an
opportunity and started seeing
an opportunity that you were
going to make a lot more money
if you did it on your own than
if you are advised by
Blackstone.
A lot of banks saw it,
however, this is a very
interesting--
I forgot when--a lot of banks
saw it,
but they decided not to do it
for one very basic and valid
reason.
The fact that if you do private
equity you start competing with
your clients,
and that is supposed to be the
sin number one in a service
organization.
However, the hubris of Goldman
was such that Goldman believed
that they were smart enough and
good enough to be able to manage
the companies.
It was a conscious decision,
there was a debate,
I remember it because I was
part of the debate,
I was not part unfortunately of
the debate of going public,
but I was--I was on the outside.
Actually I was--can we joke?
I was actually cheated because
I thought I was going to be in
the next partnership,
and so the partnership was
going public in 1999 and I was
up for election in 2000,
the big prize was postpone or
snatched to a limited,
so actually--
Prof: Pretty good prize
as we all know.
Paolo Zanonni:
Yeah it was a very good
prize, but I was part of the
private equity one.
Prof: Can I get you to
talk for a minute about how
Goldman manages its
relationships with power in
government and other branches of
society,
not just in the states but
worldwide.
Paolo Zanonni:
As me and you have
discussed,
I think that investment banking
is a business where culture is
very important and in all of you
that are going to be here on
Wednesday,
you'll see that when I speak
about Enel/Endesa take over,
the financial variables are
important,
but I will say that the
variables that determine winning
or losing sometime,
what we call soft variables,
but have little to do with
prize and finance.
For a global firm that operates
in this business it is very,
very difficult,
if not impossible,
to be able to understand the
complexities of the business
culture in which it operates.
Your best way to understand
those complexities and to avoid
the landmines that are in
different business cultures is
to get someone that knows the
business culture of that
particular culture very well,
so you end up selecting a group
of advisors,
in any nation in which you
operate,
that have a very deep
understanding of that particular
business culture and can guide
you and your client through that
particular culture.
I want to give you an example
that is so--if not we have too
abstract.
I want to give you an example
that it's--actually it's
personal to some extent.
Goldman was very late compared
to the other firms in moving
overseas.
Goldman started a small
operation in London in 1987,
when JPMorgan was big,
when Lehman was big,
when Meryl was big--no Meryl
started a little later,
but definitely when Morgan
Stanley was big,
and at one point the problem
that the Goldman people sent
overseas faced was how do we
get--
how do we enlarge in Europe
without making too many
mistakes?
The usual traditional way of
American firms to do that was to
send investment bankers from the
U.S.
and waited until they learned
the various cultures.
A very smart banker,
Goldman, who,
by the way, is one of the first
graduates of these SOM;
when he had the responsibility
of Europe he said--the reason
why I know it and I say it's
personal because that's the way
in which I wasn't counted.
He said, "Wait a second,
here we have to do something
totally different.
We have to select for every
nation where we operate,
someone that maybe is not a
banker,
who cares, but that knows that
business culture very
well," and so we had a
generation of lateral hires.
Me, my colleague in France,
one in Spain,
one in Germany,
one in England,
one in Holland,
one in Sweden,
none of them came from
investment banking;
very few of them came from
banking.
My French colleague came from
the States,
and when I did my interview
with John Soren before the
selection I said--
he said what would you like to
do, I said,
"How can I think about
going into investment banking,
I can't even count.
I can't count now.
I can't balance a
checkbook."
He said, "Don't worry,
we have hundreds of people that
can do that,
and we will give you a smart VP
that knows everything about
investment banking,
but you can operate an Italian
business in
>
I said, "I think so."
He said, "Do you under--we
want to have twenty clients,
no more in Italy,
or fifteen clients.
Do you know which client we
want and which we don't?"
I said, "I think so."
He said, "Do you know the
way the client we want to
operate inside?"
I said, "I think so,"
and he said,
"Okay, who cares if you
can't balance a checkbook?"
Goldman became the first
investment bank in Europe from
1994 to 1997 in three years,
when in 1993 it was well below
everybody else,
and it is due to that
particular creativity of John
>
who saw it clearly,
at least at this cultural
business.
How can I send an American or
British in Italy?
They don't even speak the
language.
Or in France they--I mean how
can you?
You ever try to do a deal in
France, or in Spain,
even for someone that has
a--some sort of exposure to
different business culture like
myself.
I would never be able to do it.
Like someone else would like to
try to do it in Italy,
try to understand how Fiat
works, or Enel thinks,
or only
>
operates.
Prof: So when--in the
context of the states you sent a
beaten up, Dartmouth linebacker
to Washington?
Paolo Zanonni:
Hank was--now the story
about Hank is he has always been
a Republican.
Prof: Do you want to
give your little imitation of
his voice style?
Paolo Zanonni:
Paolo--his real voice
style was,
the real imitation,
"Paolo go and get the
business,"
at 3:00 in the morning.
Hank has always been a
Republican.
He--if you talk to him,
he ascribed his success at
Goldman with the fact that he
didn't know what to do when he
got out of The Harvard Business
School and he went to work for
The Nixon Whitehouse in the
domestic affair division,
and he finds himself at 24/25
immediately after Watergate,
and everybody about him is
either in jail or had to resign,
so he becomes the most senior
person in that department and he
has to deal with the CEO.
He has to deal for a year and a
half with the CEOs of large
corporations,
and he learns,
and at the end he decided he
doesn't like the government and
he tries to get a job at Goldman
and he gets hired,
and what he was always telling
me he would say,
see the real skill that I had
was not what they taught me,
The Harvard Business School,
but the fact that I spent a
year and a half in interacting
with CEOs and CFOs from the
largest corporation because I
was at The White House and there
was--
nobody was more senior than me.
So he had been--Bush tried to
get him to be the Secretary of
the Treasury,
to my knowledge which is
limited, at least twice before
he accepted.
At one point he decided that it
was time to let Glen Klein be
the chairman and that was a
perfect exit.
Prof: Last question for
today, a simple observation
would be that Goldman has
essentially bet its life on the
quality of the people.
Just meaning all the things
you're talking about,
plus something to do with just
sheer mental horse power,
smart people.
Paolo Zanonni:
There is a reasonable
amount of smart of people.
Wait--
Prof: Don't overstate
here Paolo.
Paolo Zanonni:
No, there is a reasonable
amount of smart people,
but do you know what the
characteristic--you know it.
I mean everybody who goes to an
Ivy League school would know it.
Determination,
it's almost as important as
brain power,
and definitely
Goldman--definitely you will not
get a chance,
not even of becoming a VP,
not a partner,
if you are not determined.
The associate and the analyst
work 100 hours per week,
for years, for five years,
seven years,
and ten years.
The partners work 70 or 80
hours per week until they
retire;
unless you are ready to do
that, no way.
Prof: And if the phone
rings--
Paolo Zanonni:
If the phone rings--
I told you, Hank was used
too--when he was the chairman,
Hank was used to listening to
voicemail,
because now we communicate via
email,
then we communicated only via
voicemail.
In a firm that was--that had
$25 billion in revenues,
you could leave a voicemail to
Hank Paulson,
and unless he was on a plane,
you got an answer in less than
five hours,
and if he was on a plane,
it depends how long the flight
was,
but fifteen hours you got your
answer after fifteen hours.
Prof: Terrific,
so please review the slides for
Wednesday, and let's thank Paolo
for this very interesting
conversation
Paolo Zanonni:
Thank you.